[Music]
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car got your small
inside voice in here son there's a gun
[Music]
[Music]
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world you get peace back
i think you might be forgetting what you
do for a living
take the gun every job i do somebody
dies i'm not that guy anymore
some conflicts require a gun
[Music]
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase you said you wanted simple
for your first job back it doesn't get
simpler
mine dude i don't even know you
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
evan
where's the briefcase oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it was just here
we are right on settle everything that's
ever happened to you this is gonna sting
this let
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you tomorrow
i'm sure you want to talk this out no
particularly nice okay
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you